we are treated as second-class citizens
Puerto Rico's governor Ricardo Rocio is
frustrated he says hurricane Maria
disaster funds are taking too long to
arrive and he blames Congress why is the
same process in Florida or in Texas it
takes a week what it takes four months
Rocio is not alone on Tuesday nearly two
dozen Puerto Rican activists were
arrested in the u.s. capital demanding
Congress provide more financial aid to
the Commonwealth
what larico claims it needs ninety four
billion dollars in aid Congress
appropriated twenty three billion well
less than two billion has been sent I
want to see shovels in the ground and
and and things being built houses being
built to code I want to see a power
system that's under construction that
will withstand a storm Mike Byrne says
FEMA's effort has been unlike any
hurricane a response he's seen spending
over six billion dollars so far sixteen
million dollars has gone to San
Sebastian where the mayor blames San
Juan not the fence this town took
control of his circumstances we lifted
ourselves up frustrated after not seeing
power restored in a month the town
created volunteer brigades including
retired linemen to restore power and
clear debris on their own he says the
problem isn't FEMA funding the governor
should have acted with more urgency and
he should have taken charge of the
utility company immediately firing those
who weren't doing their jobs on Tuesday
the governor appointed a new head of
prepa
the bankrupt government-owned power
utility widely blamed for the islands
failing electric infrastructure 5,000
businesses are now closed and expected
to never reopen Johnny Ramos president
of a manufacturing company says time is
running out compounding the crises
Puerto Rico is bankrupt tomorrow
Treasury secretary Steve minuchin will
meet with the governor here in Old San
Juan to secure the terms for a two
billion dollar deal minuchin says he
wants to ensure taxpayers interests are
met Brett Brian Ellis in Puerto Rico
tonight Brian thanks